when I pulled into the coffee shop there
was a guy that was kind of blocking the
thing and I go but I always try to do
the quick one
because the second you go bang you're a
dick
and it depends on what the person's
doing you can do it back if they're
being an ignoramus or if they're trying
to be a dick you could just
Bae until they move
so
I go and he moves all good great I was
nice he was nice loved the dude God
after I all that [__] happened the guy
that guy was took another parking space
right neither here nor there but he was
in the parking he was in the coffee
place and he says
uh dude
bucket list and I said huh and he says
Chris I was in christalia's way
I'm like oh yeah it's all good that was
you in that car and he says yup crazy
and I said hey well you know it's all
good man we got through it he says yup
do you have a dentist
and I said uh
yeah but I haven't I haven't been in a
while yeah
Why'd You Come to Me
and I was like you're a dentist and he
said yeah
and I said uh
uh you know
okay
but
you know what I was thinking
I'll never see this guy after this you
know
you know what I'm saying
imagine when somebody says you know the
feeling you get when you when you say
I'm an adult I'm 43. some of you guys
are 43. some of you guys are 35 some of
you guys are 50 right
imagine somebody says hey
come to my birthday party on Friday
night
what do you think you think oh uh
I want to be home but maybe I can but I
kind of don't want to but maybe I should
and a party is the most fun thing you
can do
dental work hey guy
go away
dental work is the worst thing to do
and this guy's like hey
let me drill into your teeth for a
little bit stranger
so I'm like okay
because you don't just
I gotta get to a position I could have
been
this is the thing man my wife's always
like you got to be nicer to people and I
she's right so but it's like that kind
of means lying sometimes
so I'm just like all right yeah he says
can I get your number I'll just text you
with my assistant and we'll set
something up and I say
five five five you know like we're not
like we're in a junk movie but that's
the fake number thing five yeah sure
here we go here's my number I leave the
this is awesome dude set you up I leave
I get a group text let me just even I
don't even know if I can find it but I
get a group text
this was a while ago let me pass through
these
texts that I have Simon Rex BLB
that's my freaking
famous comedians
Bert Kreischer famous
Charles Barkley
Sammy Davis Jr hey CBS chill dude I'll
I'll be there you know
here we go
I love it says maybe and then the
dentist's office
how they know
hi Chris please meet my office manager
at
the place
hey and then to the office manager can
you work Chris into our schedule for a
comp oh compt
[Music]
for a compt
exam X-rays and teeth whitening and or
cleaning please
Yahoo dude what the [__]
I didn't even read it dude you want to
[__] work man
[Music]
why is it here
you want to work me in dude
sensational
dude
when they call my name
[__] man I should have hit him up
damn that's
wow [__] missed it he said Thursday or
Friday well didn't even ghosted my new
dentist
[Music]
[Laughter]
well you know what you win some you lose
some I literally didn't even read it
until right now wow dude what a surprise
puppy surprise sometimes you meet a
dentist and you [__] don't do this
[__] and you should have done the [__]
you know
[Music]
crazy crazy